there's such a cute moment between you
and Millie Bobby Brown at the Enola
homes 2 premiere what was it like
getting to work with her again
I love working with Millie she's she's
such a bombastic personality uh there's
I mean people always say you know we end
up behaving just like our characters but
we really are uh we're like we're like
brother and sister and and we we annoy
each other we make fun of each other we
tease each other but we support each
other as well and it's it's a pleasure
working with her she's such a keen mind
she's a wonderful actress and a
brilliant producer and I can't wait to
see where she carries this already
magnificent career yeah do you make fun
of Millie Moore does Millie make fun of
you more
I think Millie makes fun of me more but
then me saying nothing makes fun of her
more
it's true she doesn't get the reaction
she wants yes yeah I mean that that's
I've I've learned from her from the
first movie that we have we we have a we
have a good relationship it's good fun I
love that uh did it surprise you at all
that the first film took off the way
that it did that it just inspired kids
all over the world
it's I mean I I'm always careful with
expectations and
it's always wonderful when it when
anything like that does affect people
and gives people a feel-good feeling
especially during that time I think it
was really important to make people feel
something positive because a lot of
people were struggling and there's
wonderful messaging to it as well it's
very empowering language and and
messaging for young people in a fun
story and that's the key bit it's making
the story fun with a serious empowering
message which is interwoven in it and
both movies do that and I think it's
wonderful Sherlock Holmes is a genius at
solving Mysteries if you had to team up
with an actor that you've worked with on
a previous film to solve a mystery in
real life who would you pick
um if I had to team up with an actor
which I worked with on a previous film
what a great question
um I'm trying to think of who would be
the best uh
oh goodness me that's really tough you
could say Dwayne Johnson just for the
fans
[Laughter]
you know what you know what I'm gonna
avoid the obvious answer the fan pleaser
um
um
I
ah darn it there's there's a really good
answer in there somewhere you know I'm
gonna hold off from that answer for now
because I know it's a really good answer
and I and I don't want to give the wrong
one and then remember afterwards be like
no I can't believe I forgot so and so so
totally totally understandable then I am
going to throw this out there before I
get the wrap showdown between Dwayne
Johnson and you who is winning because
you know people can't wait for Black
Adam and Superman
yeah well I mean okay there
there is so much to discuss about that
and and the time will come to discuss it
um I think you know uh where where I'm
putting my money but
um time will tell time will tell I love
that so much you're so much fun thanks
so much thank you very much take care